ah
uh guys there's six of us and there's
seven thrones who's who's that for
well whoever it is i'm gonna love them
no matter what
because they're an automatic part of the
family
i can say uh i could say that uh i
as far as i know black adam is not going
to be in the second shazam
uh because the idea is that they want to
go and
do a standalone black adam movie first
and then like this so it would kind of
do a third shazam and a second black
adam kind of like that
yeah that's where we would because he's
the he's like the ultimate bad guy
for captain marvel shazam right like
black adam like that they're
doppelgangers right they're like they're
the evil twin to who i am
so that's gonna be like the final battle
if we do that in the second movie then
where do we go after that i don't
it would just be a movie just sitting
around playing video games for the third
one that would be very boring
or not i'm a very interesting
video game player um so yeah i think
that's
i think that's the idea is that we'll
but we definitely that's the plan
is to get there but just to pace it out
however it needs to face sound
hi everyone happy comic con week so we
finally have zachary levi spilling some
of the tea
on what's going on behind the scenes
what the grand plan is for shazam
versus black adam pretty much in line
with what i was thinking a couple weeks
ago when we got some of the deleted
scenes hinting at black adam within the
universe so we'll break it all down
the rock was also talking about the
black adam movie at the recent premiere
of his fast and furious spin-off movie
so i'll explain what he said about it
too
because it's comic con week we'll still
do that imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite shazam or black
adam moment on the video
because of the joke that zachary levi
just made i'm going to call it now
the post-credits scene for the shazam vs
black adam movie
is just going to be them playing video
games together like mortal kombat
how do you how do you do it how do you
call an airstrike what can i bring what
about one of those like
package thingies i'm bleeding out and i
need you
to spray can you use the package thingy
bring
they had a funny moment like that during
the shazam movie right after billy got
his powers where he
and freddie are playing video games
together while he's in shazam form
just imagine the most hulked out version
of the rock sitting next to him while
he's in shazam forum just going at each
other in some crazy fighting game
listening to him talk about that it's a
little bit clearer now why they actually
deleted this scene from the movie
because originally this scene would have
happened at the very end of the film
when they come back to the rock of
eternity they
sit down and if we would have seen this
in the theater we would have naturally
just assumed they're trying to tease
black adam in the next movie
when zachary levi is telling us that's
not the case no he's coming it's going
to be a big deal but not till a little
bit later
but what does this timeline mean for the
plot of the black adam movie in the plot
of the shazam sequel both of which
they're probably going to start shooting
next year we know that they're shooting
the black adam movie next year and we'll
see that during 2021
we know that they green lit the shazam
sequel so we know that they're making it
but they haven't said exactly when
they're gonna start shooting i'm
assuming
sometime next year after they shoot the
black adam movie
based on what he's saying and what the
rock has been saying it sounds like the
black adam movie is gonna jump
back and forth between present day and
the past to tell his origin story and
how he became
teth adam using the version of his
origin story that they established
during the shazam movie
but they were vague enough with that
that they can actually play with it
quite a bit during the black adam movie
like he took revenge on man by
unleashing the seven deadly sins but why
did he do that
who is he fighting who's the villain of
that movie going to be who's worse than
black adam
the way that they set him up is that his
family's killed when he was young
the council of wizards at that time are
growing weaker with age and they choose
him
as successor to guard the world against
the seven deadly sins
keeping them contained in the rock of
eternity the secret that they don't tell
you during the shazam movie though is
that their other job and this would have
been black adam's other job before he
bailed on it and
turned on mankind is protecting the
earth lands from the other seven realms
of magic so there's seven different
realms of magic
they're all just super crazy they'll
explore them in the shazam sequel we'll
learn why they're so dangerous and why
it's so important to keep them separated
but way back when black adam got his
powers originally that would have been
one of his jobs too
watching that magical powerpoint
presentation that the wizard gives billy
we know that black adam at some point
succumbs to his rage in xax's revenge on
the people of the world by releasing the
seven deadly sins
there was another deleted scene that i
did a video about last week where we
learned that the wizard then tried to go
subdue black adam with what power he had
left because they had just given black
adam some of their power so they're
weaker than they would have been
the seven deadly sins use that
opportunity to poison the minds of the
other wizards on the council causing a
big civil war
which they eventually begin to recapture
the sins but not before some of the
wizards
turn on each other kill each other and
then themselves the deleted scene
implies some really hardcore wtf moments
in these flashbacks so i don't know how
they're going to tune that for the black
adam movie but presumably we'll see a
version of that in
flashbacks the wizard shazam eventually
traps black adam for all eternity using
his greatest spells that's right the
shazam family the shazam lee can
cast spells just like any other big
magic user zatanna
constantine dr fate within the dc
universe they just don't know how to do
it yet they haven't learned how to use
all their abilities
then over the next several hundred years
he captures the rest of the seven deadly
sins
and traps them in the rock of eternity
in that orb that you see during the
movie
then spends the next several hundred
years or however long looking for
another champion to take his place until
you get to that scene at the beginning
of the movie with dr savannah showing up
we know mr mind is going to be the main
villain or one of the main villains of
the shazam sequel as he tries to use dr
savannah to take control of the seven
realms of magic
fun fact mr mind is actually from the
magic lands he's from the wild lands
which are populated with a bunch of
talking animals
including takitani the tiger in the
classic
captain marvel shazam comics it was just
a regular tiger but in the new dc
rebirth shazam
comic book he's an actual tiger that
walks around on two legs and talks like
a human so i'm assuming that he's going
to show up during the shazam sequel
they still haven't said anything about
who the main villain of the black adam
movie is going to be
deep cut if you saw the rock in the
mummy movies and then saw scorpion king
you know that in the mummy movies he's
this ancient evil warrior king that was
turned into a giant scorpion in present
day by the gods
but he started out as more of an
anti-hero in the villain of his scorpion
king origin movie
was a way worse warlord who killed his
family and he became this reluctant hero
of the people
until he was forced to make a deal with
the devil so to speak
so do not be surprised if you see a
similar type of villain in the black
adam movie
someone terrible enough that it feels
justified that black adam releases the
seven deadly sins on him as revenge by
the end of that movie
and then also at the end of the movie
set up his plot in present day getting
ready to face off with the shazam family
aka
the shazamly guys there's six of us and
there's
seven thrones who's who's that for
so tentative timeline for all these
movies black adam movie is
next that'll probably be 2021 shazam two
right after that purge zachary levi
black adam showing up in the post
credits for that then either shazam
three shazam versus black adam two years
after that
in 2023 or if the black adam movie does
gangbusters huge numbers maybe they
fast-tracked black adam 2 in
2023 and then do shazam versus black
adam the year after that
hard to say whether or not warner
brothers would want to release two
shazam movies in the same year counting
black adams and shazam movie
but let me know in the comments who do
you want the villain of the black adam
movie to be
they could pull all kinds of deep cuts
from the comics vandal savage felix
faust
mordrew morgan le fay clarion niron
mr mind is even supposed to be pretty
ancient so they could use him as well
but i do like the idea of vandal savage
versus black adam because vandal savage
is functionally immortal
he has instant tissue regeneration so it
doesn't really matter how powerful black
adam is he could pound
vandal savage into the ground and he
would regenerate immediately
but after shazam faces black adam
probably by that time warner brothers
will be ready to try another justice
league film with shazam
on the team maybe with jj abrams if
everything goes well because warner
brothers just paid his company
a half a billion dollars to exclusively
develop content
for wonder brothers both movies and tv
shows so don't be surprised if you see
jj abrams doing a couple big dc movies
in the next several years
but if we're talking about the next
justice league film that's like 2024
2025 so five six years sounds like
enough time for the dust to settle from
the last justice league movie
just to put that into perspective they
didn't even wait that long to reboot
spider-man with tom holland
but it's comic con week it's time to go
crazy there's gonna be so much cool
stuff dropping this week i'll do as many
videos as i can but leave all your
requests in the comments below
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see all the comic-con
videos when i post them
but click here for my spider-man far
from home fantastic four easter egg
video
and click here to watch chris hemsworth
waste matt damon
in real life in for a guardians 3 update
you